so I just got back from South by
Southwest and unfortunately I'm homesick
today been doing a lot of email but
caught a bad bug too much traveling went
to Cincinnati and then Chicago right
after South my and not sleeping in those
places was a huge mistake but what I
really want to talk to you guys about
today was at South by a lot of people
talking and really it's been talked
about the last six months to a year
how is Twitter gonna monetize I mean
Twitter that I saw an article they yet
to monetize Twitter people bashing on
Twitter because there's no money-making
mechanism let me promise you guys
something if you do not understand that
this site right here search top Twitter
and you are a clown really really do you
really not understand that this site
right here is the pulse of our society
that every day as they get all these new
users that this becomes one of the most
important web sites in the world
and have you paid attention that I've
already sold a company to Google well
I'm gonna make a prediction that this
may need to be number two and by the way
congratulations have I just heard you're
expecting we're very close on that um
anyway I am uh completely impressed with
what Facebook is doing and I think
Facebook with their new fan page is
gonna make a major play but that still
doesn't take away the fact that search
top Twitter
the most important website for any
business if you are a business and let's
say you're in the soup business and
you're not typing in soup and then
searching and then seeing the pulse of
soup in society then you are completely
missing the boat no matter what your
business is you need to be searching
this and if you don't think that all
these search results are soon gonna be
accompanied on this little right side
with an AdWords type system by Twitter
then you're not paying attention to
smart business people to me on this date
Friday March what are we now
xx search.twitter.com is the most
important and most potentially monetized
website in the world soup look somebody
just said something else